Are you idealistic?
Are you a dreamer?
Do you see potential in others?
Then you have some of the key qualities for creating vision.
Each of us has immeasurable power to reinvent our own lives.
So let's start at the beginning.
What is your destiny? What is your unique mission in life?
To develop your vision, simply use your imagination.
You see, all things are created twice; first, in the mind and second, in physical reality.
As you develop your vision, make sure it taps into your energies and gives you a sense of calling.
Sometimes we let our history or our emotional scars limit our vision.
But vision is more powerful than that, it is infinite.
Remember, you do not have to know how to execute a vision in order to create it.
As Einstein put it, imagination is more important than knowledge.
You can free your mind to start envisioning a future which is defined by expressing your voice.